schools in new york city in the country
has been for a hundred years
it's an all-girls school very few people
know what happens at rarely but if you
live on the upper east or upper west
side you probably want your girls to get
into burley because it's
that big a deal if they do so what goes
on
at breerly exactly well in april we got
a glimpse a parent at breerley
a man called andrew gutman sent a letter
to every other parent at the school
it was long it was wildly articulate and
specific and in that letter gutman
called on the other parents
to fight back against what their girls
were learning in school
if you haven't read it you should read
it because it's a remarkable
it's a remarkable essay it stands alone
actually well a new op-ed in the hill
newspaper government describes the
reaction to his famous letter quote i've
received emails from parents expressing
devastation that their kids as young as
five
are coming home from school after being
taught to feel guilty solely because of
the color of their skin
andrew gottman joins us tonight mr
governor thanks so much for coming on i
wanted to meet you i i really thought
that your letter was a
was remarkable um in how precise and
well
expressed it was and how powerful it was
what kind of
reaction did you get i have to ask
socially i mean you live in new york you
send your
daughter to one of you know one of the
premier schools everyone i have a
daughter of burley or spencer it's like
a big thing
and you go and basically kind of take
the school down how do people respond
yeah i think the response was polarizing
clearly at the school you find out very
quickly who your friends are
and who they're not who avoids you who
finds you toxic but
it was very polarizing at the school we
got a lot of support
privately the school as i know you
reported on you know wasn't so happy
about it the administration
sent out a what was a highly criticized
letter
um you know critical of my letter but it
was really uh
very criticized for calling uh you know
the students frightened for getting this
letter at home so
it was a polarizing response and then
the response i got which i know you
alluded to
more broadly was very very different
thousands of emails from parents
and teachers and grandparents and
concerned citizens
from all over the country overwhelmingly
supportive
which is great but the flip side of that
is
i had no idea how entrenched and how
widespread this issue of critical race
theory was
across the country all over i knew it
was in new york city schools i knew it
was in some california schools but i had
no idea
how quickly this had spread to schools
public
private even religious schools all over
uh this is an enormous problem and i
think we have to fight this
much harder and i appreciate that you've
been one of the very few that have been
talking about this and we need that but
we really need to fight this
well parents need to fight it and that's
what i found so thrilling about your
letter i mean for people not familiar
with new york getting a girl into
brearly is like getting a kid into
harvard like you tell your friends
you're very impressed that your child
so to do this really was an
act of it was a transgressive act
why did you do it and did anyone tell
you not to do it
well no one knew we were going to do it
except my wife and my daughter
um i had thought about doing it at the
very beginning of the year when we saw
what was happening in the school i mean
really this critical race theory had
been seeping into the school over the
years into a lot of other of these
independent schools
but it was in the last year since blm
and george floyd
that this accelerated to an enormous
degree
and i had thought of doing it at the
very beginning of the year but we said
no what let's try to get parents to
speak up
we'll talk to a lot of parents and i did
that and a lot of parents agreed that
the direction of the school was
one that they did not agree with uh they
were very unhappy with what
was going on but as you know there is a
people are terrified of speaking up on
this issue so we couldn't get people to
speak up
and we said you know what when we
decided not to re-enroll our daughter
for next year
i said i've got to send this letter and
the idea of the letter was not
to change anybody's mind it was you know
not to
educate anybody on anti-racism training
what was going on in the school
it was really to help people to speak up
to give them some cover a little bit of
ammunition but mostly some cover to say
hey
we need to speak up on this issue what
you did is revealed the administration
that school is so deeply unimpressive
and stupid the headmistress
couldn't even respond to you i mean just
in one sentence were you surprised that
they didn't even try
and justify what they're doing are you
surprised how dumb they are
i was well i
no i mean i this is the way they played
this is every time something comes up
they double down on this they
they sent a letter just the other day
and by the way i'm excommunicated from
the school so i no longer
get emails my wife gets them but you
know they they
these institutions um are there for the
institution
public schools there for the teachers
unions and the teachers these private
schools are there for the institution
they are not
here for education and for the kids so
no
i really wasn't he wasn't very surprised
i think your letter will i think your
letter will be one of those documents
that we preserved from this moment i
hope so it deserves it
andrew gottman i appreciate you coming
on thank you thank you very much
so throughout the corona pandemics hey
sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else